le contexte marqué par la flambée des
prix de l'énergie et les risques en
matière d'approvisionnement en énergie
nous avons en effet organisé en octobre
dernier une première table ronde
consacrée aux enjeux stratégiques de
l'énergie pour l'Union européenne et une
deuxième au mois de décembre sur le
thème de la réforme européenne du marché
de l'électricité l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par par la Russie il y a un peu plus
d'un an et les sanctions décidaient en
représailles ont bouleversé les marchés
mondiaux de l'énergie et ont conduit à
une réorientation des flux
d'approvisionnement pour l'Europe
troisième plus gros consommateur
d'énergie au monde en quelques mois
c'est donc dessiné une nouvelle
géopolitique des énergies brutalement la
guerre en Ukraine a mis en évidence la
forte dépendance de l'Union européenne
aux importations de combustibles
fossiles en particulier russe
même si tous les États membres n'étaient
pas dans la même situation de ce de ce
point de vue jamais sans doute depuis la
création de la Communauté européenne du
charbon et de l'acier en 1951 les
questions d'approvisionnement et de
sécurité énergétique non tue une si
grande importance dans l'histoire de
l'Union européenne l'énergie est tout
particulièrement le gaz dans ce contexte
de guerre et devenu une arme aux mains
des dirigeants russes avant même
l'invasion de l'Ukraine la Russie avait
déjà commencé à réduire ses livraisons
de gaz à l'Europe contribuant
contribuant à renchérir les prix des
énergies déjà tendues du fait de la
reprise économique qui a suivi la crise
sanitaire
depuis son déclenchement ce sont sans
doute par ses répercussions énergétiques
que le conflit ukrainien aura le plus
affecté les acteurs économiques et les
ménages européens
en réaction l'Union européenne a
rapidement décidé de sortir au plus vite
de sa dépendance au gaz russe le 18 mai
2022 la Commission européenne a présenté
à cet effet le plan ripower U
pour assurer son approvisionnement
énergétique l'Union s'est alors engagée
dans une course effrénée à la recherche
de nouveaux fournisseurs mais aussi
d'autres ressources énergétiques
notamment le gaz naturel liquéfié la
part du gaz russe dans le bouquet
énergétique de l'Union européenne et
ainsi passer de 40% à moins de 10% en
quelques mois elle a commencé la
consommation de gaz dans l'Union
européenne a baissé de près de 20% en 6
mois ce qui est supérieur à l'objectif
que c'était fixé les états par ailleurs
la décarbonation de l'économie
européenne en jeu auquel doit répondre
le pacte vert pour l'Europe contribue
aussi à bouleverser les équilibres
géopolitiques de l'énergie
de nouveaux pays fournisseurs d'énergie
décarbonées vont émerger susceptibles de
dominer certains marchés et ainsi
favoriser l'apparition de nouvelles
dépendances l'accès à l'énergie
constitue donc plus que jamais un enjeu
géopolitique majeur de l'Europe
aujourd'hui et pour l'avenir
ce sont ces éléments qui ont conduit la
commission des affaires européennes à
organiser cette table ronde sur les
enjeux géopolitiques de l'énergie pour
l'Europe je remercie donc les
intervenants qui ont bien voulu sur en
disponibles pour y participer je vous
proposerai à chaque intervenant une
intervention liminaire de 10 minutes par
approche thématiques ainsi nous pourrons
donner la parole à nos collègues je
laisse d'abord la parole à Monsieur
Nicolas mazoutchi
vous pouvez venir à la tribune qui est
directeur de recherche au Centre
d'études stratégique de la marine vous
avez publié en octobre dernier un
article intitulé la France et l'Europe
face à la déco
d'identalisation des flux énergétiques
alors plusieurs questions quelles sont à
vos yeux les défis géopolitiques de
l'accès aux ressources énergétiques pour
l'Union européenne quels sont les
bouleversements majeurs qui sont
intervenus sur les marchés mondiaux de
l'énergie depuis le conflit
ukrainien comment l'accès à l'énergie
est-il devenu une arme dans ce conflit
et quel est l'impact des sanctions
européennes pour la Russie et aussi pour
nos économies donc 10 minutes pour votre
thématique et puis après
la ligne aura les questions après que
les tous les intervenants se soient
exprimés merci beaucoup merci pour pour
cette invitation pour vous parler
effectivement cette question de la
décontinentalisation des flux
énergétiques qui est aujourd'hui
finalement la conséquence visible de
cette situation qui a été décrite en
introduction aprèsambule à mon propos je
voudrais rappeler un phénomène
relativement sain mais sur lequel il
faut insister c'est que le phénomène
énergétique au niveau de l'Union
européenne est un phénomène carboné lié
aux hydrocarbures fossiles comme liquide
avec une prédominance bien évidemment du
couple pétrole gaz que ce soit de
manière globale dans la consommation
énergétique mais aussi quand on va
regarder dans la production
d'électricité et si on met à part vous
me passerez l'expression l'anomalie
entre guillemets statistiques françaises
avec le recours très fort au nucléaire
qui donne l'impression qu'au niveau
européen il y a une prépondérance du
nucléaire en réalité on va plutôt
retrouver là aussi de manière globale au
niveau de l'Union européenne une
prédominance justement des hy carbure
fossil donc bien évidemment tout ce qui
va avoir un impact de manière directe ou
indirecte sur la question de
l'approvisionnement des hydrocarbures
fossiles va bien évidemment
immédiatement avoir un impact économique
mais aussi géopolitique fort sur la
question gazière ça a été rappelé
effectivement si on se projette
avant justement cette invasion de de
l'Ukraine par la Russie on se rend
compte que on est dans une situation qui
est relativement simple c'est que le gaz
vient un très majoritairement de Russie
effectivement 40%
suivi par la Norvège mais qui est quand
même relativement loin derrière on voit
que la part de la Norvège est deux fois
moindre que celle de la Russie avec
ensuite une kyrielle de fournisseurs on
va dire plus ou moins important suivant
notamment suivant leur distance
géographique alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on
se retrouve dans cette situation il faut
voir que c'est une croissance qui est
quasi continue depuis le milieu des
années 70 cette dépendance à la Russie
et pour une raison relativement simple
je m'a un petit peu sur le gaz parce que
la situation du gaz est une situation
qui est très paradoxale dans le sens où
pourquoi est-ce qu'à partir du milieu
des années 70 on se met à consommer du
gaz et notamment du gaz russe dont on ne
va faire j'allais dire qu'approfondir la
dépendance c'est parce que le gaz est à
cette époque là conçu comme une énergie
de sécurité
on est dans les suites du premier choc
pétrolier sur une surdépendance à l'OPEP
une surdépendance au monopole et donc il
se trouve que sur le territoire européen
je vais au-delà de l'Union européenne et
je reste sur le continent européen se
trouve un hydrocarbure qui est peu ou
pas utilisé et relativement abondant qui
est le gaz naturel qu'on va trouver
majoritairement mettant la Russie à part
en Norvège au Pays-Bas et au Royaume-Uni
donc à cette époque là le gaz conçu
comme une alternative de sécurité hors
le problème c'est que rapidement enfin
rapidement au bout d'un certain nombre
de décennies les exploitations de gaz
européennes Norvège mise à part je pense
surtout le cas des Pays-Bas et du
Royaume-Uni pour des questions
techniques économiques mais aussi
social finalement d'acceptabilité
sociale de la production finissent par
décliner de manière relativement forte
ce qui ne va faire qu'accentuer la
dépendance à un fournisseur qui est
capable de réunir deux conditions être
capable de fournir de grands volumes à
des prix relativement soutenables la
définition de la sécurité énergétique
c'est l'approvisionnement continu à des
prix soutenables un second fournisseur
c'est la Russie et ça explique pourquoi
jusqu'en 2022 on ne fait qu'accroître la
dépendance globale de l'Union européenne
aux approvisionnements gaziers russes
alors je vous ai mis aussi ce petit
tableau à droite rapidement pour vous
montrer aussi que le phénomène gazier si
jusqu'à présent je parlais en chiffres
relativement macro au niveau de la
plaque européenne même Union européenne
européenne un petit peu étendue il
recoupe des réalités relativement
différentes suivant les États membres il
y a des pays qui utilisent relativement
peu de gaz c'est le cas de la France par
exemple et quand bien même on aurait la
même utilisation totale du gaz dans le
mix énergétique ça recoupe là aussi des
situations différentes suivant par
exemple la production d'électricité qui
serait faite à partir de gaz là aussi le
cas de la France est relativement
intéressant puisqu'en France le gaz
n'est quasiment pas utilisé pour la
production électrique contrairement à
d'autres pays par exemple comme l'Italie
qui ont forcément une sensibilité
globale justement au gaz comme source
d'énergie qui est beaucoup plus importe
que ne les par exemple celle de la
France toutefois la stratégie de la
Russie avait été une stratégie
multidimensionnelle dans le sens où la
Russie n'est pas qu'un producteur de gaz
c'est un producteur de gaz c'est un
producteur de pétrole brut et surtout
c'est un producteur de produit
pétroliers raffinés et là aussi la
stratégie de la Russie avait été de
maintenir une capacité de raffinage
relativement forte qui permet à partir
du milieu fin des années 90 avec la
décroissance des capacités de raffinage
sur le territoire de l'Union Européenne
de prendre le relais sur un certain
nombre de produits raffinés notamment la
Russie pour des raisons qui tiennent en
fait à la technique de ces raffineries
mais aussi au pétrole brut qu'elle est
capable de produire en fait la Russie
était spécialisée plutôt schématise là
aussi dans la production de diesel
et là aussi de manière relativement peu
étonnante là aussi était le premier
fournisseur de diesel de la France quand
on regarde les fournisseurs étrangers
donc on va rentrer finalement sur un
double phénomène mais qui aujourd'hui un
double phénomène de la géopolitique de
l'énergie qui est la dépendance à la
matière première d'une part et la
dépendance non pas la technologie parce
que la technologie du raffinage n'est
pas une technologie complexe en
elle-même mais une dépendance à la norme
pourquoi est-ce que cette question
j'insiste volontairement très fortement
sur cette question du produit pétroli
raffiné notamment du diesel russe c'est
pas parce que la Russie est capable de
produire du diesel c'est parce que là
aussi est capable de produire du diesel
sur les normes Euro 6 et le problème est
très majoritairement là pour la France
notamment vous voyez que quand on
regarde en fait un petit peu l'éclaté de
la dépendance des 27 pays de l'Union
européenne par rapport à la Russie on se
rend compte que tous les pays ont des
dépendances relativement différentes gaz
pétrole brut produit raffinés suivant
eux-mêmes leur consommation et la
structure de leur économie on se rend
compte par exemple qu'on a un pays comme
la Hongrie qui est très dépend au
pétrole brut parce qu'il y a encore un
gros secteur du raffinage Hongrie
par exemple mais pour la France la
dépense majeure si on devait en sortir
une parmi les trois c'était la dépense
aux produits raffinés et donc cette
dépendance plutôt à une question de
norme qu'une question de technologie ou
qu'une question de matière première et
ça ça joue aussi énormément dans la
question de la géopolitique de l'énergie
aujourd'hui c'est quand vous substituez
un fournisseur qui est capable de vous
fournir un produit sur une norme
particulière c'est extrêmement compliqué
et
si je peux me permettre par rapport à
cette situation là nous avons eu de la
chance et vous allez voir que la
décontinentalisation des flux se lie
aussi beaucoup au travers de cette
question là
quand on regarde justement la dépense
énergétique de l'Europe à la Russie et
qu'on la regarde par rapport à la
dépendance des autres zones
continentales on se rend bien compte que
finalement en termes géographique avant
la guerre en Ukraine se phénomène qu'on
pourrait appeler sans que ça n'appelle
aucune conception géopolitique de ma
part mais juste en terme géographique ce
phénomène eurasiatique donc
véritablement cette dépendance on va
dire par proximité géographique
terrestre entre l'Europe et la Russie
d'une part c'est le phénomène
énergétique dominant en Europe
les autres zones géographiques notamment
pour des raisons de prix sont des zones
géographiques qui sont bien moins
importantes quand on va regarder les
trois dimensions que je vous ai
mentionnées le gaz le pétrole brut et
les produits raffinés toutefois si
aujourd'hui on regarde et qu'on fait non
pas une comparaison d'une année sur
l'autre mais une comparaison du mois de
juillet 2021 par rapport au mois de
juillet 2022 donc on n'est pas sur 12
mois glissants on est vraiment
comparaison d'une photo par rapport à
une photo on se rend compte qu'on a des
évolutions qui sont extrêmement
profondes et que cette
décontinentalisation donc cette sortie
finalement du domaine terrestre c'est
accompli et c'est accompli de manière
extrêmement forte notamment vis-à-vis de
deux zones géographiques en tous les cas
pour ce qui est visible sur cette carte
là qui sont le phénomène Atlantique
et pas forcément
partout on pourrait l'imaginer on se
rend compte qu'on a une extrême
croissance notamment de la part de
l'Amérique du Sud et l'Amérique latine
dans la question du pétrole brut et le
golf aura beau-percique donc là on se
rend compte que une fois de plus cette
maritimisation des flux énergétiques et
quand même relativement forte
et qu'elle recoupe parfois des
situations qui sont
très intéressantes au sens géopolitique
du terme je prends un cas très
particulier j'ai insisté beaucoup sur la
question du diesel parce qu'il touche
particulièrement la France
la solution et c'est là où je vous
disais on a eu de la chance la solution
c'est qu'en 2020 l'Inde a aligné ces
normes de production de carburant qui
sont les normes BS6 sur les normes Euro
donc la substitution a été possible pour
les carburants parce qu'on a pu trouver
un fournisseur alternatif qui non
seulement était en surproduction par
rapport à sa propre consommation
nationale mais qui en plus avait la
capacité et une fois de plus à deux ans
près ce serait pas passé la même chose
avec la capacité de fournir sur la même
norme et donc vous rendez compte par
rapport à l'habitude historique qui sont
on va dire un petit peu les mois de
janvier et février 2022 sur ce graphique
là quand on regarde l'évolution des
importations européennes justement de
produire affiner indien on est sur une
véritable explosion explosion qui durera
jusqu'à un certain temps l'Inde étant
aussi un pays dont la consommation
énergétique est donc pétrolière
nationale augmente très fortement pour
l'instant l'un des temps sur capacité de
raffinage elle ne leur restera pas
indéfiniment
donc là aussi ça va poser des questions
relativement relativement importante et
ce qui est ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'on en vient à manifester
quelque chose de relativement clair dans
la stratégie de la Marine nationale mais
aussi de la France et de l'Union
européenne depuis quelques temps c'est
la naissance de l'Indo Pacifique
l'Indopacifique qui pouvait sembler être
ce phénomène relativement lointain mais
quand on va le penser dans le domaine
énergétique et pas comme un espace
séparé c'est à dire avec une zone
indopacifique qui se situerait quasiment
aux antipodes du continent européen mais
dans une continuité Indo-Pacifique au
méditerranéenne pour l'approvisionnement
énergétique vers l'Europe on se rend
bien compte justement qu'avec la
croissance de cette dépendance gazir et
pétrolière au fournisseurs du Proche et
Moyen-Orient mais aussi la croissance de
cette question par rapport à l'Inde là
on a véritablement la création de ce
complexe indopacifique géopolitique qui
devient prégnant dans le domaine
énergétique et dans le domaine
économique
a-t-elle enseigne que effectivement si
on regarde aujourd'hui l'évolution qui
est celle par rapport au statistiques
qui sont disponibles aujourd'hui de
l'Union européenne donc si on fait une
moyenne sur avril à décembre 2022 donc
on n'a pas les chiffres complets de
l'année 2022 mais on peut faire glisser
la moyenne on se rend compte que la
Russie est toujours présente sur le gaz
mais qu'elle commence à être remplacée
par d'autres fournisseurs et notamment
des fournisseurs de plus en plus
lointain et de plus en plus maritimes
donc effectivement l'explosion de la
question du gaz naturel liquéfié ce qui
d'ailleurs quand on va regarder le cas
français est encore plus prégnant le cas
français même si pour la France le gaz
est un phénomène énergétique marginal
par rapport à ce que peut être le
pétrole ou ce que peut être le nucléaire
quand on regarde cette
décontinentalisation des flux gaziers au
niveau français on se rend bien compte
qu'on est passé d'un système qui était
plutôt très continental européen avec ce
couple Norvège Russie à quelque chose
qui est beaucoup plus ouvert et
notamment je vous invite à regarder
l'explosion de la place du Qatar
qui était un acteur totalement marginal
jusqu'en 2022 et qui aujourd'hui tend à
devenir l'un des principaux acteurs de
la fourniture gazir européenne donc
réinsiste sur cette question de la
décontinentalisation vis-à-vis de l'Indo
Pacifique je vous disais un
Indo-Pacifique au méditerranéen puisque
un certain nombre de pays essaie de se
positionner ou dans la production ou
dans le transit de ces matières
premières le cas de la Turquie par
exemple est extrêmement intéressant
puisque la Turquie bien avant d'ailleurs
l'invitation de Vladimir Poutine à un
Ratchet perdohann à devenir un nouveau
hub énergétique et la Turquie
ambitionnée de devenir un hub
énergétique depuis de très nombreuses
années et aujourd'hui quand on fait une
carte de l'ensemble des infrastructures
alors celles-ci gazières dans la région
on va dire en mer Noire Méditerranée
orientale nord du golfe arabo Percy
qu'on se rend bien compte que la Turquie
se positionne comme un phénomène
centralisateur des approvisionnements
pour en fait être la porte d'entrée du
Sud-Est européen et au-delà du Sud-Est
européen notamment en utilisant le
phénomène gazoduc puisque le gaz par
gazoduc est structurellement moins cher
que le gaz naturel liquéfié donc le
principe étant de faire le trajet
maritime le plus court mais la Turquie
permet d'avoir des systèmes de décharge
qui permettent en partie en fait
d'injecter ce gaz naturel liquéfier
notamment venant du Qatar mais pas
exclusivement la Turquie a des contrats
avec l'Algérie le Nigéria d'ailleurs
l'Algérie le premier client aujourd'hui
export de l'Algérie en terme gazier
n'est pas un pays européen c'est la
Turquie
ce qui est historiquement une révolution
dans ce domaine là donc la Turquie se
positionne par rapport à ça donc
nouveaux équilibre
géopolitiques effectivement on a parlé
de la stratégie européenne de ripower
you donc là je vous ai mis en
récapitulatif un petit peu les
différentes actions mais surtout il faut
louer et ça n'arrive pas forcément tous
les jours en France la stratégie
européenne non pas qui a été mise en
place en 2022 mais celle qui est mise en
place depuis 2009 car notamment grâce à
l'encouragement extrêmement fort de
l'Union européenne sur la construction
de terminaux de regazéification gaz
naturel liquéfié sur la révision de la
directive gaz en 2017 qui oblige à avoir
des gazoducs à double flux sur
l'ensemble du territoire de l'Union
Européenne sur un certain nombre de
choses dans ce domaine là on a permis
justement d'avoir l'infrastructure qui
permettait d'absorber le choc en tout
cas au niveau européen toutefois
j'insiste sur un phénomène l'Europe n'a
jamais été conçu comme le continent du
gaz naturel liquéfié historiquement dans
toutes les analyses le continent du gaz
naturel liquéfié c'est l'Asie l'Europe
c'est le continent du Gaspard tube
or aujourd'hui et avant cette guerre
tous les systèmes d'exportation de gaz
naturel liquéfié prenez en compte cette
donnée relativement basique qui était
que le marché du GNL c'était l'Asie
aujourd'hui on a un renversement
renversement qui pour l'instant n'est
pas visible parce qu'on n'a pas de
retour à la croissance chinoise donc là
il faut aussi alerter sur le fait que le
retour à la croissance chinoise créera
forcément une compétition entre zones
géopolitiques dont on montre l'Europe et
cette zone justement Asie Pacifique pour
l'approvisionnement de gaz naturel
liquéfier et tant entendu que le gaz
naturel liquéfié à lui-même une chaîne
de valeur particulière dans laquelle il
y a un phénomène qui est dimensionnant
et c'est le phénomène de la construction
navale aujourd'hui la construction
navale des méthanis elle est à 90% en
Asie du Nord c'est Chine Corée du Sud
Japon et c'est aujourd'hui le phénomène
dimensionnant pour l'instant une fois de
plus pas de retour à la croissance
chinoise forte donc pas de demande
particulière et pas de compétition
extrêmement forte si demain on a un
retour à la croissance chinoise forte
bien évidemment on aura une compétition
entre
une brève question qu'on s'est posé lors
de votre exposé
les produits raffinés et la filière
indienne semblent intéressante mais le
brut indien il est doux alors
effectivement cette question très
intéressante puisque l'un de nos
produits quasiment pas de pétrole brut
donc l'Inde importe du pétrole brut
d'une multitude d'acteurs dont la Russie
et on a vu l'explosion des importations
de tous les acteurs historiques qui
fournissent à l'un dont la Russie donc
il y a effectivement une part alors qui
par
globalement l'Inde va se fournir pour à
peu près 40% dans les pays du Golf arabo
Persique un tiers en Russie et
le reste on va dire c'est éclater entre
un certain nombre de pays notamment
africains mais donc on a vu une
explosion de la l'achat indien de
pétrole brute russe justement pour y
compris pour faire tourner ses
raffineries mais ça n'est pas que du
bruit
bien merci je vais donner maintenant la
parole à Monsieur et j'ai gourrel donc
vous êtes professeur titulaire de la
chair économie des matières premières du
Conservatoire national des arts et
métiers et qu'aux directeur du cercle du
cercle cyclopé qui regroupe les
spécialistes des marchés mondiaux de
commodité en tant qu'expert des marchés
de matière première quel est votre
analyse du rôle géopolitique du gaz vous
êtes l'auteur d'un article paru en
novembre dernier dans la revue
confrontation Europe sur la stratégie
gaziaire de l'Europe comment les flux
énergétiques à destination de l'Europe
et en Europe ont-ils été bouleversé par
la guerre en Ukraine vous avez
globalement 10 minutes pour nous
présenter ces aspects
merci beaucoup de me donner la parole
écoutez je sais très en phase avec ce
qu'a dit mon collègue autour finalement
de la dépendance européenne et de la
maritimisation de des échanges des
statistiques pour commencer également
en 2021 l'Europe au sens large je prends
des statistiques du pétrolier BP à
consommer 571 milliards de mètres cubes
de gaz donc à peu près 400 milliards
pour lui à 27 on a produit 210 milliards
on a importé 232 milliards dont 167
milliards en provenance de Russie des
gazeuxducs Russes donc vous voyez comme
la évoqué mon collègue notre
extraordinaire dépendance à la Russie et
si on raisonne non plus en volume et en
valeur on a vu en 2022 une explosion de
la facture gazière française 2021 on
était à 21 milliards de dollars dont 13
milliards sous forme gazeuses et 6,4
milliards sous forme liquide donc le
fameux GNL donc je vais beaucoup parler
2022 on passe à 63 milliards de dollars
donc 27,7 milliards sous forme gazeuse
et signe de la modification de nos
approvisionnements on est à 33,7
milliards sous forme liquide donc une
facture qui a été multipliée par 4 et
c'est là où j'aurais peut-être une toute
petite divergence par rapport à mon
collègue sur finalement nos nouvelles
dépendances mais je raisonne non pas en
volume mais en valeur sur ces 37,7
milliards de factures gazières pour le
gaz liquide on a 6 pardon 16,7 milliards
en provenance des États-Unis alors qu'en
2021 on était juste à un milliard donc
on voit une explosion de notre facture
vis-à-vis des États-Unis la Russie qui
est en valeur notre
deuxième fournisseur sur le GNL une
facture à presque 6 milliards ensuite
vient le Qatar l'Algérie et l'Angola
donc clairement qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé entre 2021 et
2022 il fallait remplacer et remplacer
au plus vite les 167 milliards de mètres
cubes en provenance de Russie et
l'Europe n'avait pas d'autres choix que
de se tourner vers le GNL et
majoritairement donc le GNL américain
alors une fois qu'on dit ça
est-ce que on peut considérer que ce GNL
est une solution est-ce que c'est une
solution de court terme bien évidemment
je l'ai dit nous n'avions pas le choix
est-ce que c'est une solution de moyen
terme
la question est quand même beaucoup plus
compliquée
à évoquer quelques petits mots très
rapides pour que vous compreniez la
réalité du marché du GNL c'est un marché
dont les volumes ont absolument explosé
on était à 140 milliards en 2000
aujourd'hui on est à peu près à 510
milliards et ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on a eu des vagues successives
c'est-à-dire que on a eu le Qatar dans
les volumes ont très fortement augmenté
poursuivi par l'Australie dans les
volumes ont également fortement augmenté
pour égaler ce du Qatar poursuivi par
les États-Unis
dont les volumes pareil sont au niveau
quasiment de du Qatar et de l'Australie
c'est-à-dire autour de 100 milliards de
mètres cubes donc c'est un marché qui a
énormément grandi et qui est devenu de
plus en plus flexible comme l'a évoqué
mon collègue pour historiquement pour
avoir du GNL il faut des structures de
liquéfaction et des structures de
regazification et ça ça coûtait enfin ça
coûte toujours lorsqu'elles sont
terrestres extrêmement chères et donc on
avait un marché qui sur cette base était
finalement assez rigide parce que avant
de construire vos structures de
liquéfaction il fallait vous assurer que
vous ayez des clients à l'autre bout de
la chaîne et puis avant d'avoir des
structures de liquéfaction il fallait
vous assurer que vous ayez des
fournisseurs donc on avait pour
sécuriser c'est toujours la tendance de
fond des contrats long terme a pris
indexé généralement indexé sur le
pétrole mais il y a eu une filée dans
cette compétition entre les pays que
j'évoquais et probablement dans la
sous-estimation de l'importance des
énergies renouvelables on a eu le
financement de surcapacité en tout cas
de surcapacité à l'époque et donc
finalement de volume
qui n'était pas intégré dans ces
contrats de long terme et qui donc
pouvait être négocié en base spot au
comptant c'est-à-dire avec des prix au
jour le jour et c'est aussi pour ça que
l'Europe a finalement payé très cher
sont son gaz en 2022 il y a eu aussi de
la flexibilité parce qu'on a levé avec
l'arrivée des États-Unis sur ce marché
du GNL et des pratiques finalement
commerciales anglo-saxonnes avec aussi
le l'Europe une levée de ce qu'on a
appelé les clauses de destination
c'est-à-dire que vous n'étiez pas
contraint de garder votre GNL sur le sol
national lorsque vous l'aviez importé
vous aviez aussi des formes de
financiarisation avec des swap qu'on
appelle des swap cargo vous pouvez
finalement échanger les destinations
vous approvisionnez vos européens auprès
de l'Australie et puis finalement l'un
de sa provisionner auprès du Qatar mais
vous pouviez soiter en fait les
livraisons de gaz et suis une
flexibilité je voudrais insister
là-dessus lié à des éléments
technologiques qu'on appelle les frsu et
les FLNG qui sont des structures non pas
sur terre mais des structures offshore
c'est-à-dire en mer qui finalement ont
permis alors le FLNG et techniquement
plus compliqué mais qui ont permis en
fait au pays producteur au petit pays
producteurs d'aller sur le marché et
puis au pays importateur comme l'a fait
l'Allemagne par exemple ou la France au
Havre de d'augmenter les capacités
d'importation de manière rapide donc
c'était finalement un marché
flexible et c'est aussi en ça que ça a
été une réponse à la problématique du
gaz russe
mes interrogations sur le GNL et
notamment le gel américain je voudrais
les partager avec vous de manière très
simple d'abord je sais bien que nous
parlons des États-Unis je sais bien que
nous parlons d'un partenaire historique
mais je crois que nous ne pouvons pas
négliger les conséquences géopolitiques
diplomatiques de cette nouvelle
dépendance le Qatar on pourrait
l'inclure également de cette nouvelle
dépendance au GNL notamment dans un
contexte de rivalité croissante avec la
Chine et d'une interrogation nécessaire
pour l'Europe dans dans cette échiquier
nous devons nous interroger également
sur les conséquences environnementales
de ce GNL
puisque ça reste quand même du gaz de
schiste et puis un élément sur lequel je
me semble-t-il nous n'insistons pas
suffisamment parce qu'il y a une forme
de tropisme européen qui est que
finalement en 2022 l'Europe a asséché le
marché du GNL
il y a un effet pris très net et donc
tous les flux de GNL de par cette
flexibilité géographique
contractuelle tous les flux de GNL je
schématise ont été vers l'Europe quid
des pays en développement ou des pays
émergents c'est-à-dire le Pakistan par
exemple le Bangladesh ainsi de suite qui
finalement se retrouver sans GNL l'ont
payé plus cher avec finalement un coût à
la fois économique et évidemment un coût
environnemental parce que dans les
effets de substitution quand le gaz
naturel devient trop cher et bien on
passe au charbon et ça me semble-t-il ce
n'est pas suffisamment intégré dans nos
réflexions
ça a été également évoqué nous avons
importé du GNL dans un contexte très
particulier c'est-à-dire dans un
contexte où la demande chinoise de GNL
était faible elle était en baisse de 20%
par rapport à 2021 et il est bien
entendu contenu de la structure spot du
marché que si la Chine revient fortement
sur le marché du lgnl il va y avoir un
effet pris important dès lors qu'on ne
serait pas en contrat long terme et ça
reste quand même une partie de la
réalité de de l'Europe et la
problématique gaziaire n'est pas
terminée même si l'hiver était doux on a
une problématique pour pour l'hiver
prochain donc quels seront le niveau des
prix alors je sais bien que nous avions
nous avons mis en place une forme de
prices cap mais qui finalement
coordonnée au fait qui est pas de
tension sur les approvisionnements donc
il faudrait quand même discuter de tout
ça avec un effet naturellement même s'il
va y avoir une réforme du marché sur
l'électricité et donc sur la puissance
industrielle européenne
troisième point que je voudrais évoquer
regardez où se trouve les structures de
liquéfaction aux États-Unis actuelle et
en construction elles sont toutes dans
le golfe du Mexique et vous en
conviendrez c'est peut-être pas la zone
géographique la plus stable d'un point
de vue météorologique
on a du côté de l'offre une grande
concentration à l'été 22 il y a une
structure de liquéfaction qui s'appelle
Freeport LNG qui pour des raisons
industrielles a subi un accident c'était
moins 4 % de l'offre mondiale donc vous
voyez bien que on a aussi un effet de
dépendance à l'offre aux États-Unis il y
a pas l'idée forcément d'une stabilité
absolue
la diversification que nous offre le GNL
est également relatif parce que pour
avoir du GNL a priori il faut des
métiers que 150 métalliers certes ont
été commandées en 2022 sur une flotte de
641 métaniers aujourd'hui mais ces
métalliers devraient arriver en 2026 et
l'essentiel de ces métiers sont
construits ça a été dit également au
Japon mais surtout en Corée du Sud
historiquement et ce qu'on observe c'est
une très forte montée en puissance de la
Chine sur la construction des métalliers
qui sont complexes il n'y avait me
semble-t-il qu'un chantier naval en 2022
capable de construire du métallier il y
en a quatre aujourd'hui donc encore une
fois la diversification par rapport à ça
c'est quand même assez assez relatif
enfin
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
estime un certain nombre de d'hypothèses
bien évidemment mais que la demande
d'importation
européenne pourrait augmenter en 2023 de
40 milliards de mètres cubes alors que
la capacité les capacités disponibles
incrémentales sont de 20 milliards de
mètres cubes donc on a cet effet de
dépendance pour terminer je suis un peu
long
[Musique]
la question à mon avis importante et
finalement est-ce que cette guerre en
Ukraine est un accélérateur de la
transition environnementale ou plutôt de
la transition énergétique où finalement
une forme de frein je pense que ce n'est
pas une question
évidente quoi qu'on en dit c'est à dire
que bien évidemment que on a cette idée
de promouvoir le renouvelable mais il y
a un effet prix qui est quand même
important il y a aussi la question du
caractère pilotable de cette énergie et
puis et puis même si ce n'est pas le
sujet de table ronde vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que sur les trois grands
piliers de la transition
environnementale c'est-à-dire
électrification des transports
énergie par carbone je dis
volontairement bas carbone en incluant
le nucléaire et plus d'infrastructures
électriques sur ces trois piliers nous
avons de manière systématique un effet
de report sur les ressources minérales
les batteries Lithium c'est du nickel
avec un marché qui est
extraordinairement stable c'est du
lithium il n'était pas instable et pris
en flambés maintenant il chute c'est du
cobalt c'est également du cuivre c'est
également des terres rares et on voit
que sur ce segment là la Chine a un
monopole sur les terres ces 87 % parlait
du raffinage pour le pétrole 87% de la
chaîne de valeur des terres c'est-à-dire
de l'extraction jusqu'au raffinage sans
maîtrisés par la Chine bien évidemment
que l'Europe a réagi là-dessus mais
avant d'avoir une forme de souveraineté
je pense que voilà il va falloir
travailler travailler dur et travailler
avec beaucoup de pragmatisme je
terminerai là-dessus nous avons une
lecture qui est une lecture finalement
assez industrielle de la transition
environnementale assez économique en
disant finalement les ressources on va
prendre des participations il faut que
nous ayons une lecture diplomatique de
ces ressources minérales mais quand je
dis une lecture diplomatique c'est une
lecture finalement
regarderait l'ensemble des matières
premières pour accéder à une ressource
il faut peut-être en proposer d'autres
et c'est pour ça que je milite
activement pour une diplomatie des
matières premières et pas uniquement une
diplomatie de l'énergie ou une
diplomatie des ressources minérales je
vous remercie merci la parole est
maintenant madame Blandine Barrault
analyse de l'équipe des perspectives
énergétique mondiales à l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie pouvez-vous
nous préciser le rôle de l'agence en
matière de politique de l'énergie
qu'elles ont été les actions de l'agence
pour prévenir les pénuries
d'approvisionnement et sortir de la
dépendance à l'égard des importations de
gaz russe
quels sont les incertitudes qui pèsent
sur l'approvisionnement énergétique des
pays européens notamment pour liverpo
prochains et qu'elles sont finalement à
vos yeux les enjeux géopolitiques de la
transition énergétique pour l'Union
européenne pour 10 minutes aussi à peu
près
merci et merci pour l'invitation qui est
fait aujourd'hui à laieu donc je
commencerai par les implications de la
crise au niveau mondial avant de revenir
parce que le sujet vous intéresse sur le
rôle qui a endossé l'agence dans la
gestion de cette crise auprès des
gouvernements
donc un point d'abord sur les
applications à court terme sans être
trop longue parce que les intervenants
qui m'ont précédé je pense l'ont fait de
manière
extensive et très clair juste peut-être
trois points le premier c'est que
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie
considère qu'on traverse actuellement
une crise une ampleur inégalée qui n'est
que partiellement comparable au choc
pétroli des années 70 parce qu'elle
touche tous les secteurs de l'énergie et
elle est bien plus complexe à gérer pour
les gouvernements pour les acteurs
économiques que ces chocs de prix des
années 70
au-delà des problématiques de dépendance
en matière de ressources
cette crise et le premier intervenant la
rappeler à mise en lumière des décennies
d'investissement inadéquates dans la
transition énergétique c'est-à-dire dans
les domaines qui permettraient de
s'affranchir de la dépendance aux
énergies fossiles comme le renforcement
de l'efficacité énergétique ou le
recours à des sources des carbonées
et pour être clair et cité un petit peu
plus de comment dire être un petit peu
plus clair sur les coups
si on regarde ce que les gouvernements
européens ont jusqu'à présent consacré
en urgence à la protection des
consommateurs on est presque à 350
milliards sur un peu plus d'un an depuis
septembre au moment des premières
tensions sur sur les marchés du gaz
c'est la moitié de la valeur de la
facilité européenne pour la reprise et
la résilience qui a été mise en oeuvre
pour aider les États membres à
répondre aux effets économiques de la
crise du covid donc c'est littéralement
le coup de ce manque d'investissement
dans la transition énergétique et
comme je crois l'ont appelé également
les autres intervenants il y a encore
beaucoup pas faire pour s'affranchir
véritablement de cette dépendance en
Europe comme ailleurs ce qu'on appelle
l'énergie énergo intensive encore une
structure de coût dominée à 65% par les
coûts de l'énergie
donc la perspective de rupture
d'approvisionnement cet hiver est
désormais largement derrière nous mais
nous restons pour notre part assez
réservé sur les perspectives en Europe
perspective encore une fois
d'approvisionnement et encore une fois
ça a été rappelé il y a une seconde si
l'hiver prochain devaient être plus
rigoureux que celui que nous ont
traversé encore et que la reprise
économique en Chine
qui reste le premier importateur mondial
de gaz et de pétrole était
particulièrement forte
on pourrait vraiment en Europe faire
face à des turbulences et un risque à
nouveau de rupture d'approvisionnement
je précise également que contrairement
aux approvisionnements pétroliers qui
comme vous le savez font l'objet d'un
embargo les livraisons de gaz russe
n'ont jusqu'à présent pas être
interrompus mais pourraient l'être dans
le futur à l'aune d'évolution notamment
géopolitique ce qui laisserait également
peser un risque supplémentaire sur les
approvisionnements européens si on
regarde maintenant les implications de
la crise à moyen et long terme
la première donnée et l'agence est assez
claire et un message assez fort et on
est assez convaincu là dessus on a
vraiment identifié une perte de position
dominante de la Russie on pense que la
Russie regagnera pas
son statut de première exportateur à la
fois de pétrole et de gaz qu'elle avait
avant la crise même si elle continue à
vendre sur les marchés internationaux
elle a de moins en moins d'acheteurs
parmi les pays développés ces revenus
d'exportation diminuent si on regarde
les recettes cette année en janvier par
rapport à janvier 2021 on a une perte
d'environ 40%, bien évidemment
principalement dû à la perte de son
principal client qui était l'Europe qui
représentait 75% de ses importations
exportations gazières et 55% de sympa
ces exportations pétrolières
pour aller un petit peu plus vite sur le
sujet avec l'embargo pétrolier les
sanctions européennes la part de la
Russie dans le commerce international a
désormais diminué de moitié en un an
ce qui est brutal
les sanctions signifient également un
accès désormais très limité aux
technologies avancées qui permettent en
fait d'exploiter au maximum les puis
pétroliers russes qui font partie des
des
depuis qu'on appelle mature en fait les
parmi les plus vieux qui ont besoin de
ces technologies qui sont souvent
propriétés des entreprises étrangères
pour être exploitées à leur juste mesure
et remplacer les volumes précédemment
livrés aux clients européens ne peut se
faire pour la Russie de manière rapide
la manière la plus efficace de délivrer
des grands volumes ça reste le pipeline
il faut environ une si on se projette
sur la construction d'un pipeline qui
permettrait par exemple de relier les
puits russes au marché chinois on
envisage mal de voir une telle
infrastructure se concrétiser avant au
moins une décennie donc les pas de temps
sont quand même pas pour également
impacter cette cette position
commerciale russe une autre donnée
importante en termes de géopolitique et
encore une fois l'intervenant précédant
l'a rappelé mais je vous vraiment parce
que je pense que c'est pas assez
forcément vu dans la crise actuelle donc
je voulais le rappeler c'est que les
pays en développement sont les premiers
touchés par cette crise mondiale
et de loin ils se sont des pays qui
doivent désormais composer avec des
finances publiques fortement entamées
par la crise du covid-19 la hausse des
coûts d'importation et des niveaux de
dettes publiques et de leurs entreprises
notamment du secteur énergétique
fortement aggravés par à la fois la
crise du covid et la crise énergétique
beaucoup de pays en développement sont
désormais dépassés par la surenchère des
prix sur les marchés de l'énergie je
crois qu'on a beaucoup lu dans la presse
notamment cet été le cas de ce pétrolier
qui s'acheminait vers le Pakistan qui
connaissait en tout cas en août des
tempéra température proche de 55 degrés
et une sécheresse extrême la dynamique
de négociation sur les marchés la
dynamique de négociation des prix à
en fait mener ce tanker à ce retourner
vers le marché européen il y a eu un
demi-tour brutal et donc une privation
de ressources pour le Pakistan et donc
comme bien évidemment le pressentait
cette compétition par les prix que
beaucoup de pays en développement sont
voués à perdre à d'ores et déjà de
graves conséquences sur leur sécurité
énergétique et leurs horizons de
développement économique et social
l'Agence internationale d'énergie un
petit peu regardé l'impact sur l'accès à
l'électricité pour la première fois en
2022 on a un recul du progrès en la
matière
c'est un fait tragique et historique
qui se déroule essentiellement en
Afrique subsaharienne et donc les
conflits d'accès à la ressource risquent
de peser très fortement sur les
relations politiques géopolitiques entre
les pays développements les pays
émergents et les pays de l'OCDE qui ont
bien évidemment une sensibilité et une
compréhension très différente également
de la source du conflit et donc de
l'origine de la rareté de la ressource
c'est quelque chose qui encore une fois
va peser sur la relation géopolitique à
venir
dernier point sur les conséquences de la
crise notamment les pays de l'OCDE et
notamment en Europe et je voulais
préciser avant de
d'aborder ce dernier point que l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie fait partie
des observateurs que l'on peut qualifier
de des plus conservateurs sur le sujet
de la transition énergétique et
notamment du développement des énergies
renouvelables pour être très clair nous
avons au cours des dernières années
était enfin nos chiffrages et nos
évaluations ont pu être
[Musique]
qualifié de moyennement optimiste sur le
développement des renouvelables donc ce
que je m'apprête à vous livrer je pense
ne sera pas le fruit de de travaux menés
par une organisation
comment dire historiquement très pro
renouvelable
mais d'une organisation dont
l'indépendance est bâti aussi sur la
génération de données fiables et encore
une fois non biaisé
donc d'abord on a vu je n'y reviendrai
pas les gouvernements européens
rechercher de nouveaux fournisseurs
d'hydrocarbures mais également et c'est
le point le dernier point sur lequel je
souhaitais insister se tourner vraiment
vers les énergies décarbonées pour
remplacer le gaz russe et on a notamment
enregistre en 2022 une hausse de plus de
40% des capacités éoliennes et solaires
additionnels installés en Europe ce qui
est un record
historique un accroissement des ventes
de véhicules encore une fois uniquement
sur le marché européen de 15%, les
pompes à chaleur qui sont des
équipements alors pas forcément très
vieux technologiquement parlant mais qui
n'avaient pas jusqu'à présent vraiment
envahi le marché européen ont vu leur
vente augmenter de plus d'un tiers cet
hiver
on a des orientations soit en faveur du
recours soit de la poursuite ou de
l'accroissement à la génération
nucléaire en Belgique aux Pays-Bas et la
io a publié ce matin la les estimations
en termes d'émission de CO2 pour l'année
2022 qui confirme que ces orientations
structurelles contribuent bien à l'aide
des carbonisations de des éco-numées
européennes puisque l'Union européenne
enregistre en 2022 une baisse de 2,5%
ces émissions de CO2
et dans un contexte où on a notamment
encore une fois
bon certes une clémence de l'hiver mais
également un recul de la production à la
fois nucléaire et hydroélectrique cette
baisse des émissions ne peut être être
attribuée qu'à la hausse des sources de
production des carbonées du nucléaire au
renouvelable
c'est soit c'est soit stratégiques se
retrouvent au niveau mondial le dernier
point que je souhaitais faire passer sur
les implications géopolitiques de cette
de cette crise qui sont en tout cas on
le pense à laïque là pour durer c'est
que la donnée fondamentale qui s'impose
de plus en plus et qui se lie à travers
tous les chiffres que je viens de vous
donner et au-delà des préoccupations de
sécurité énergétiques c'est désormais
celle de la compétitivité économique
à travers des solutions industrielles
je pense que tout le monde a en tête la
loi qui est passée cet été aux
États-Unis alors en français la loi de
sur la réduction de l'inflation une
flèche
c'est 400 milliards de dollars qui sont
consacrés au secteur énergétique la plus
grande partie va aller renforcer la
production manufacturière américaine
d'énergie des carbonées ainsi que
l'innovation sur le sol américain et je
rappellerai que pour atteindre
l'objectif net zéro émission en 2050
l'Agence internationale d'énergie à
regarder ce que ça donne en terme de
technologie et la moitié des
technologies qui sont nécessaires à
l'atteinte de ce de cet objectif ne sont
actuellement qu'en phase soit de
démonstrateur soit de développement donc
consacrer des ressources à l'innovation
ça va être la clé également du
leadership dans cette dans ce domaine là
on voit le Japon et la Corée mettre en
oeuvre des politiques similaires la
discussion
que vous suivez certainement été
largement ouverte dans le cadre de Henry
Power et des plans présentés par la
commission je crois il y a 15 jours en
matière de refonte de la politique
industriels européenne
donc en conclusion la crise a lancé une
nouvelle forme de compétition
industrielle vers un modèle de carboné
et les régions et les secteurs qui en
tiront les bénéfices les plus
conséquents à la fois en termes de
croissance et d'emploi seront ceux qui
seront se positionner avant les autres
d'où cette nouvelle donnée de la
compétition internationale je ne sais
pas si j'ai encore quelques minutes pour
évoquer le rôle de l'AIE comme vous
l'avez demandé dans le drone dans la
gestion de cette crise deux minutes
c'est faisable
donc l'aie est une agence qui a été
fondée sur un mandat de sécurité
énergétique en 74 mandat qui a depuis
cru et s'est développé pour englober des
aspects de transition énergétique nous
représentons
intermédiaire de nos pays membres et
partenaires des États qui englobe 80% de
la consommation énergétique mondiale et
à ce titre nous avons pu mener un
certain nombre d'actions
d'abord en termes de
lancement d'alerte puisque des mois
avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine nous avons
publiquement voir nos préoccupations
concernant les distorsions de prix sur
le marché du gaz que nous avons
directement
identifié comme lié à la réduction des
livraisons russes vers l'Europe ce qui
nous a valu par ailleurs des petites
attaques informatiques assez
handicapantes
nous travaillons avec chacun des
gouvernements de nos pays membres et
partenaires nous avons à qui nous avons
fourni une semaine après l'invasion
russe de l'Ukraine d'abord un plan en 10
points pour réduire la dépendance au gaz
russe puis un autre plan 10 points pour
éviter des ruptures d'approvisionnement
pétrolier pendant le pic estival est
préparé l'hiver et si on regarde le
détail de ces mesures beaucoup ont été
depuis mises en oeuvre par les États
l'agence au titre de son mandat
historique qui vise à assurer les
conditions de la sécurité énergétique a
également coordonné deux déblocages de
stock stratégiques de pétrole dans les
12 derniers mois et qui s'est déblocages
représentent les deux plus grands en
quantité de nos 50 ans d'existence et
plus récemment nous avons mis à la
disposition de la commission européenne
et des États membres une série de
recommandations destinée d'évaluer
éloigner le risque d'une rupture
d'approvisionnement gaz dans l'Union en
2023 dont les chiffres notamment sur les
décalages sur les capacités de
traitement viennent d'être appelés nous
coordonnons également un dialogue
ministériel autour d'une quarantaine de
pays sur les questions de marché gaziers
internationaux et je terminerai avec les
voies de coopération un peu
exceptionnelles que nous avons mises en
place avec l'Ukraine qui n'est pas un
État membre de layer nous avons signé un
programme de travail conjoint et nous
travaillons actuellement activement avec
les autorités ukrainiennes notamment en
matière de renforcement de la sécurité
du système électrique ukrainien qui
comme vous le savez a fait face à de
nombreuses attaques qui ont provoqué des
disruptions et qui est citée par les
autorités ukrainiennes comme la priorité
numéro 1 en termes de sécurité humaine
je devrais dire d'ailleurs humanitaire
nous avons répondu et nous accroissons
nos coopérations dans ce domaine là je
vous remercie j'espère en avoir pas été
trop longue je reste à votre disposition
s nous ont éclairé sans faire de jeux de
mots quand on parle de production
d'électricité mais
on passe on va passer tout de suite aux
questions si si vous en avez je suppose
que oui mais donc on va commencer pierre
aux olias puis Claude Kern
monsieur le Président
madame messieurs je tiens vraiment à
vous remercier pour la qualité de vos
présentations et je vous le dis sans
flagorn sur le président mais
d'auditions
on voit très bien qu'on est en train de
prendre conscience et de suivre un fil
rouge que que je pourrais résumer avec
de façon très très simple c'est que on
comprend de plus en plus que on peut pas
discuter de marcher et d'économie sans
penser géostratégies et que la pensée
géostratégique elle devient fondamentale
et les politiques économiques découlent
de la pensée géostratégique et pas
l'inverse et ça je pense que c'est un
changement fondamental et je vous
remercie d'éclairer la commission des
affaires européennes sur quelque chose
qui est qui est tout à fait
importante
la question qu'on va se poser c'est quel
est le rôle de l'Europe dans la
redéfinition d'une nouvelle politique
géostratégique est-ce qu'elle a été
conçue pour ça d'abord est-ce qu'elle a
les moyens de le faire et on comprend
bien que c'est au cœur au cœur du
problème
l'autre question que j'aimerais vous
poser c'est que il n'y a pas une
superposition exacte entre nos intérêts
économiques et nos intérêts
géostratégiques et
a fortiori nos alliances militaires et
on voit très bien que par exemple au
sein de le temps il peut y avoir des
divergences vous l'avez dit avec les
États-Unis mais encore plus avec la
Turquie où on voit très bien que le jeu
de la Turquie et très distinct de de nos
intérêts et par rapport à ça on sent que
certains repères de la guerre froide ne
sont pas complètement disparus n'ont pas
complètement disparu et je pense
notamment à ce qui
vous me direz si je me trompe à la
recomposition d'un clan des non alignés
et on voit très bien que ce qui se passe
en Amérique du Sud l'Inde etc et un
train de reconstituer quelque chose et
l'Afrique et tous ces pays intéressent
énormément aujourd'hui la Russie et la
question que je vous pense est-ce que la
Russie est pas en train de travailler
avec ces pays pour constituer des relais
tiers et retrouver des pertes de marché
qu'elle a perdu dans la relation directe
avec l'Europe
l'intérêt très fort de la Russie pour
l'Asie mais aussi pour l'Afrique est-ce
que ça peut s'expliquer par la volonté
de la Russie de contourner le blocage
européen tel qu'il existe pour passer
par la marge moi je m'intéresse un peu
au Caucase le rôle de l'azerbaïgence
c'est exactement celui-là
l'Azerbaïdjan sert de cellules de
recyclage et contournement des interdits
économiques qui pèsent sur la Russie
voilà je veux pas être plus long mais je
voudrais vous remercier encore une fois
pour la qualité de votre propos
merci merci président à mon tour de vous
remercier parce que j'avais préparé un
certain nombre de questions auxquelles
vous vous avez déjà répondu mais j'en ai
il me reste quand même une que je me
permets de vous poser parce que depuis
plusieurs années la France et l'Europe
ont décidé d'investir dans la production
d'hydrogène pour des carboner un certain
nombre de secteurs et accompagner la
transition énergétique
toutefois on constate que l'essentiel de
l'hydrogène produit aujourd'hui les à
partir d'énergie fossile
pour sortir de cet écueil la France mise
notamment sur l'hydrogène bas carbone
qui
lui est fabriqué à partir d'électricité
d'origine nucléaire or à l'heure
actuelle l'hydrogène bas carbone n'est
pas prise en compte dans les objectifs
de décarbonation fixées par lieu c'est
d'ailleurs l'un des enjeux
de la révision de la directive sur les
énergies renouvelables avec 3 qui doit
intervenir prochainement une première
victoire a été remportée récemment si on
peut appeler Sainte Victoire puisque la
Commission a reconnu que l'hydrogène
produit à partir d'un réseau
d'électricité essentiellement décarbonée
comme les celui de la France pouvaient
être considéré comme de l'hydrogène
renouvelable donc comptabilisé dans les
objectifs de l'UE
mais peut-être faudrait-il replacer ces
débats dans un contexte plus global à ma
question est l'hydrogène est-il une
technologie d'avenir qui permettrait à
l'Europe de renforcer sa souveraineté
énergétique et les plus grandes
puissances ont-elles de l'avance ou du
retard sur notre continent à ce sujet
si
alors qui répond sur la géopolitique
d'abord et puis ensuite sur sur la
question hydrogène
de votre remarque je voudrais réinsister
sur finalement sur la base de ce qui a
été dit par par mes collègues sur la
dimension absolument systémique de la
crise que nous vivons et donc ces
aspects géostratégiques si je dois
précisément propos systémique parce que
avec l'augmentation des prix de
l'électricité on a des effets de report
par exemple sur l'industrie européenne
une tonne d'aluminium c'est 15000 kWh
pour pour la production donc on a une
extrême sensibilité et donc on a
vraiment des effets l'acier également le
zinc donc on avait vraiment des effets
de report c'est également cette
augmentation des prix du gaz
entraîner une augmentation très forte du
prix des engrais dans un contexte où le
réchauffement climatique pèse sur les
rendements agricoles vous imaginez ce
que ça peut faire je rappelle que on a à
peu près minimum 20 millions de
personnes en situation d'insécurité
alimentaire élevée dans la corde de
l'Afrique et c'est pareil ça c'est il
faut que ce soit pris en compte en fait
dans notre dans notre stratégie globale
d'où l'idée de cette diplomatie des
matières premières il faut revenir en
réalité à ce commerce pacificateur qui a
été qui avait été mise en place au
lendemain de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
c'est la fameuse charte de la vanne
c'est l'organisation internationale du
commerce qui est devenu l'OMC et qui a
pris effectivement un virage assez
libéral et qui a
peut-être pas assumé totalement cette
dimension pacificatrice que qu'on voyait
dans le commerce international on est
dans un contexte d'affaiblissement du
multilatéralisme et donc il faut revenir
à mon avis à la base de ce qui était le
multi latéralisme vous évoquez monsieur
le Président la CECA il faut revenir sur
ces éléments là et lorsque vous regardez
la charte de La Havane vous voyez en
fait un point qu'on a tous oublié qui
est que oui vous pouvez diminuer les
droits de douane bon et les barrières
pas lui faire ça c'est un élément mais
vous devez considérer les matières
premières comme étant un produit tout à
fait particulier en raison des enjeux
géostratégiques qu'ils portent or on a
depuis 30 ans 40 ans nous n'avons pas vu
cette cette dimension là dans sa
dimension encore une fois systémique
donc il faut me semble-t-il à côté de
des conférences sur le climat avoir des
conférences dédiées mais pas uniquement
sur l'énergie sur l'ensemble des
matières premières j'ai une image un peu
triviale qui est de dire que aujourd'hui
on sait qu'il faut qu'on se mette au
régime dans cette transition énergétique
parce qu'on n'aura pas de transition
énergétique sans sobriété et pas
uniquement sobriété énergétique mais une
sobriété matière sauf qu'il faut décider
le menu et le menu c'est bien très
précisément qu'est-ce que tu vas
consommer en énergie fossile en énergie
renouvelable la problématique africaine
est une problématique
ultra ultra importante sur
l'électrification du continent africain
sur l'Afrique subsaharienne on est à
moins de 50%
et on ne peut pas avoir de développement
économique on ne peut pas avoir de
sécurité globale si on n'a pas
l'électrique fication du continent
africain posant la question du rapport
de l'Europe à l'Afrique et posant la
question du rapport de l'Europe à aux
énergies fossiles disponibles je pense
au gaz disponible en Afrique très
rapidement sur l'hydrogène alors
évidemment tout le monde en parle je
voudrais vous faire une remarque
triviale qui est que l'hydrogène c'est
un vecteur d'énergie ce n'est pas une
énergie donc pour moi c'est un report
il y a des éléments très intéressants
par exemple sur la décarbonation de
l'acier en fait il y a un report du
problème puisque si vous voulez
l'hydrogène vert ou jaune c'est-à-dire
nucléaire même si on doit plus utiliser
ses couleurs il vous faut des énergies
renouvelables si vous faut des énergies
renouvelables il vous faudra ressources
minérale donc on revient entre
guillemets au point de départ et je
crois que la question du stockage de
l'électricité par l'hydrogène à pose un
certain nombre de problèmes en termes de
rendement
pour compléter au moins sur la je vous
remercie oui effectivement sur la
géopolitique dont vous vous posiez la
question sur sur l'Union européenne
alors l'Union européenne fait des choses
les partenaires européens font des
choses mais il faut aussi voir que
l'Union européenne est aussi limité par
les compétences qui qui lui sont
dévolues l'article 184 du TFUE qui règle
la compétence énergétique compétence
partagée entre les États membres et
l'Union européenne n'est pas centré sur
la question justement de la sécurité
énergétique n'en parle pas effectivement
depuis 2015 on a eu la question de
l'union de l'énergie mais on va dire que
jusqu'en 2022 où tout le monde jusqu'au
prémices de de cette guerre la sécurité
énergétique était volontairement ou
involontairement d'ailleurs un angle
mort de la pensée de la commission donc
effectivement il y a des choses qui
peuvent se mettre en place à partir de
là
soit au sein de l'Union européenne soit
avec des partenaires européens la France
notamment donc là je parle en tant que
marin et leader d'une mission européenne
qui n'est pas une mission PSDC donc qui
est une mission qui réunit des
partenaires européens de sécurisation du
golf a beau Persique qui est qui
notamment est orientée vers la
sécurisation de nos approvisionnements
énergétiques et qui prend d'ailleurs de
plus en plus d'ampleur ou nos articulons
quand même 17 marines européennes et une
fois de plus c'est une mission
européenne de facto mais non PSDC donc
il y a potentiellement des choses à
faire sur la question des alliances des
alliances militaires et de leur rapport
l'OTAN à créer en 2012 un centre
d'excellents sur la sécurité énergétique
et si vous prenez depuis le sommet de
Chicago 2010 jusqu'au dernier sommet de
l'OTAN aujourd'hui la sécurité
énergétique ne cesse de prendre de
l'ampleur dans les actes finaux des
sommets de l'OTAN ce qui marque aussi la
volonté de l'OTAN de prendre cette
question là à coeur et l'interaction eu
autant justement sur cette ce caractère
très précis de la sécurité énergétique
puisque ça n'est pas une compétence
native de l'OTAN ça n'est pas une
compétence naturelle de l'Union
européenne c'est une articulation sur
laquelle il y a de plus en plus de
travaux qu'il faut de plus en plus
travailler mais qui n'articulation
complexe y compris à l'aune de ce que
vous mentionnez qui était la question de
la présence des États-Unis de la Turquie
qui sont on pourrait aussi par exemple
parler de parler de l’autriche en sens
inverse mais l'un est en membre d'une
organisation et pas l'autre ce qui pose
ce qui pose évidemment un certain nombre
de problèmes notamment sur la question
de la Méditerranée orientale avec pour
l'instant il est en sommeil mon inconnu
de grosse tension notamment en 2018-2019
la question chypriote
bien évidemment entre la République de
Chypre et la Turquie le nombre de lui et
pas de l'OTAN l'autre membre de l'OTAN
et pas de lieu enfin vous vous parliez
de la question on va dire de la création
un petit peu de espèce de blog de pays
non alignés et du rapport de la Russie
voire de la Chine d'ailleurs à ces
pays-là je tiens à faire remarquer que
le dernier vote de l'Assemblée générale
des Nations Unies sur la condamnation de
cette guerre a donné un résultat
équivalent au vote précédent ça veut
dire quand même qu'on a un soutien
massif y compris de la part justement de
payer émergent ou moins avancé malgré
tout ce qui a été mentionné sur la
question de l'impact que l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie ont sur ces pays
là on a quand même toujours un soutien
très important de la part de ces pays
justement à la vision on va dire
occidentale avec énormément de
guillemets sur ce terme-là de la
condamnation ferme de cette agression
russe donc pour l'instant on voit pas
forcément ça même s'il est bien évident
que la Russie et la Chine prenne des
positions stratégiques dans le domaine
de l'énergie étendue au domaine des
matières premières matières premières
minières notamment sur l'ensemble du
continent africain voire ailleurs il ne
vous aura pas échappé on parlait du
Pakistan tout à l'heure que l'entité qui
a construit l'infrastructure de gaz
naturel liquéfié au Pakistan c'est la
Russie
donc la Russie a déjà commencé à prendre
des positions et à mon avis d'ailleurs
la Russie aura une capacité à se
retourner vers d'autres marchés à mon
sens plus rapidement qu'à l'horizon de
10 ans on peut considérer que si le
gazoduc force de Sibérie 2 est voté
rapidement côté russe et côté chinois il
devrait pouvoir entrer en action aux
alentours de 2028 2029 ce qui ne ferait
que faire dériver la Russie vers le
Pacifique et donc là aussi amener la
Russie vers l'Indo Pacifique vous savez
c'est un petit peu la marotte des marins
l'Indo Pacifique en ce moment je vous
remercie madame barreau sur sur
l'hydrogène complément merci donc
effectivement l'hydrogène représente des
perspectives intéressantes pour ces
dernières en fait c'est c'est artwab et
saxo ces dernières portions de
l'industrie lourde jeudi dernière dans
le sens où économiquement et
techniquement ces réductions d'émissions
sont très compliquées à aller chercher à
la fois pour des motifs climatiques et
également pour des intérêts en termes de
compétitivité industrielle
et donc ce vecteur d'énergie qui a
l'hydrogène reste tout de même
intéressant pour obtenir ces réductions
d'émissions et ses accroissements de
performance industrielle dans le domaine
de l'industrie lourd donc à Syrie et
offre également des perspectives
intéressantes dans le transport comme
vous l'avez rappelé l'immense majorité
de la demande d'hydrogène qui a à peu
près à 90 95 millions de tonnes pour
l'année dernière et satisfaite par de
l'hydrogène produite à partir d'énergie
fossiles la production d'hydrogène
bas carbone donc essentiellement par
l'intermédiaire d'énergie par production
basée sur des énergies renouvelables
c'est à peu près un million de tonnes
les dernières évolutions que qu'on peut
noter c'est encore une fois par
l'intermédiaire de ces plans de leur
plan de relance et de leur réponse à la
crise énergétique plus récente les
gouvernements ont eu tendance à
commettre un petit peu le paquet sur les
projets de démonstrateur
il y a encore un saut technologique à
faire il y a des
problématiques également de
[Musique]
reformatage ou d'adaptation des des
infrastructures donc tout simplement les
les gazoducs existants pour permettre le
transport d'hydrogène qui ne sont pas
[Musique]
extrêmement légers du point de vue du
coup et vous avez dans ce sens là un
projet intéressant
entre la France et l'Espagne le Portugal
qui en fait la reconfiguration du projet
M4 qui va nous apprendre je pense
beaucoup dans les années à venir sur la
faisabilité et les coûts associés à ce
genre de
reformatage en très mauvais français
et puis pour terminer sur sur cette
question là
les encore une fois les
en termes géopolitique les deux
questions que ça soulève c'est comme
l'intervenant précédent vient de le
rappeler les les problématiques les
difficultés d'approvisionnement en
minéraux critique avec une concentration
notamment en Chine des ressources
actuelles vous avez je crois la semaine
prochaine une première publication du
pardon alors je vais faire de la très
mauvaise traduction anglaise mais de la
loi cree call of loi européenne sur les
minéraux critiques qui va être assez
intéressante à suivre parce que ça
s'annonce comme la réponse de l'Union à
ces problématiques là donc avoir
l'ambition qui est portée par ce texte
et puis pour terminer
pour nous la encore une fois la question
centrale de
quand un nouveau une nouvelle énergie un
nouveau vecteur d'énergie arrive comme
ça maturité et juste un engouement c'est
celle aussi de de ses conséquences sur
les marchés de l'énergie et en terme
géopolitique également
il y a actuellement beaucoup d'appétits
d'intérêts et de papiers qui sortent sur
les perspectives de
d'utilisation des ressources hydrogène
bacarbonne sur le continent africain
parce que là vous avez un gisement
solaire bien évidemment inédit au niveau
mondial
le message que l'aïeu porte sur ses sur
ces questions là et sur la configuration
future du marché international de
l'hydrogène c'est aussi
celui de la considération du
développement humain
sachant que par l'intermédiaire de
l'accord de Paris et des négociations
internationales sur climat on s'est mis
d'accord pour limiter notre consommation
de gaz
il y a parfois je parle du gaz parce
qu'il y a un gisement il y a des
gisements fondamentaux et des ressources
fondamentales en Afrique pour permettre
de
lutter contre les problèmes d'accès à
l'énergie notamment
est-ce que des pays de l'OCDE peuvent se
permettre à la fois de porter un
discours qui vise à réclamer la
réduction de l'exploitation gazières je
parle même pas de l'exploitation et de
sur place pour desservir des marchés
domestiques africains et à la fois
mettre en place des coopérations visant
en fait à exporter ses capacités
d'hydrogène bas carbone ça va être une
partition assez difficile à jouer
géopolitiquement et si elle pourrait
avoir des conséquences encore une fois
particulières à la fois sur les
conditions d'accès à l'énergie sur le
continent africain et sur les données
futures la géopolitique des relations
internationales mondiales voilà
merci alors prends trois questions André
Richard Jean-Yves Leconte et Ludovic et
merci président d'abord merci à nos
intervenants pour la qualité de ces
exposés
aucun d'entre eux néanmoins n'a cité à
quelques moments le risque terroriste
une augmentation du risque terroriste
s'il en est on voit déjà ce qui se passe
à l'heure actuelle en Afrique mais rien
n'est exclu par ailleurs est-ce qu'il y
a
des réflexions des études qui ont été
faites à cet égard qui naturellement
pourrait avoir des des impacts
importants sur en matière géostratégique
tout particulièrement sur l'Europe
deuxièmement j'ai bien noté aussi
très intéressé par cela
l'importance
de la chier en termes de consommation
éventuelle future de GNL bien avec
naturellement les conséquences que ça
peut avoir sur le plan géostratégique
est-ce que sans être Madame Soleil
est-ce que
des études existent sur un risque de de
de
redémarrage de cette croissance chinoise
rapidement et avec naturellement les
conséquences que cela pourrait avoir
bien sûr sur les marchés mondiaux en la
matière merci
oui merci et merci pour votre pour vos
exposés et votre grille de lecture sur
la relation entre finalement les
dépendances géopolitiques et certaines
énergies mais justement puisque vous
avez évoqué en particulier la question
du gaz et des dépendances géopolitiques
moi je voudrais vous demander de ce que
vous pourriez nous donner votre grille
de lecture sur l'énergie nucléaire sur
ce biais là sachant que l'énergie
nucléaire contrairement au gaz il y a
pas que la question finalement de la
source il y a bien entendu la question
de la source du minerai il y a la
deuxième dépendance éventuelle c'est la
question du traitement des déchets et la
troisième dépendance et qui probablement
celle qui est la plus importante c'est
celle de la technologie surtout quand on
évoque partout des plans de SMR alors
que finalement ce ne sont que des
projets de prototypes ce que je
comprends plus ou moins et que le
premier qui arrivera à industrialiser
ces choses probablement sera pro
bablement le seul être capable de le
faire donc voilà est-ce que vous pouvez
nous apporter un peu votre grille de
lecture gaz dépendance sur cette énergie
nucléaire peut-être plus complexe à
analyser
si Ludovic oui merci Président Mesdames
et Messieurs
déjà je vous prie d'excuser d'être
arrivé en cours de route j'espère si ma
question a déjà été évoquée je vous
demanderai simplement de bien vouloir me
le dire vous avez évoqué
l'aspect des matières premières qui pour
moi est essentiel dans l'économie
mondiale sous différents aspects
l'aspect énergétique l'aspect
géopolitique j'aimerais vraiment me
focaliser sur l'aspect économique avec
la spéculation qui est faite sur les
matières premières et avoir votre regard
sur ce point de vue là la spéculation
existe sur les matières premières
existent depuis des siècles et latin des
niveaux aujourd'hui
enfin qui n'ont qui n'ont encore jamais
été atteint justement avec des achats
sur des des dizaines d'années en avant
par des pays qui eux-mêmes achètent des
matières premières mais qui n'ont pas
l'intention d'obtenir ces matières
premières là et je vous laisse
simplement avoir votre avis sur
votre votre regard sur cette économie
mondiale pourquoi parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'aujourd'hui les les
hommes et les femmes politiques que nous
sommes essayent de pallier
aux différents effets néfastes qui sont
créés par cette spéculation qu'est-ce
que j'entends par là
j'entends par là que aujourd'hui vous
avez certaines spéculations ces matières
premières qui créent des famines dans
certains pays vous avez sur le niveau
énergétique aussi des mines qui
aujourd'hui sont tout à fait identifiées
mais qui ne sont pas exploitées qui le
seront le moment opportun vous avez
aussi un certain nombre d'autres
matières premières qui seront mis sur le
marché encore une fois c'est le c'est
tout la définition toute la définition
de la spéculation et j'ai l'impression
que les hommes et les femmes politiques
que nous sommes aujourd'hui essaie de
pallier ce que ce que ce que cette
spéculation crée de plus mauvais dans
l'économie mondiale quel est pour vous
votre regard sur ce point de vue là
merci alors monsieur mazouti va répondre
sur terrorisme et nucléaire c'est bien
ça merci alors sur la question théorie
c'est je me permettrai d'élargir un
petit peu votre question en prenant
aussi le cas du gazoduc Nord Stream donc
en prenant aussi la question de ce qu'on
appellera les menaces hybrides qui donc
n'inclut pas forcément des groupes armés
non étatiques qui peuvent aussi inclure
des actions par proxy et ce genre de
choses là il est bien évident que
du point de vue des forces armées
françaises mais aussi de nos partenaires
européens et de l'OTAN ce sont des
choses qui sont prises en compte la
Marine nationale par exemple dispose une
expertise dans ce qu'on appelle le
contre terrorisme maritime qui adresse
justement toutes les actions
antiterroriste se passant en mer quelle
que soit la plateforme sur laquelle
s'opère que ce soit sur des navires des
plateformes offshore donc avec des
capacités des entraînements et des
doctrines qui sont adaptées à ça ça
c'est la première partie de la réponse
la deuxième partie de la réponse bien
évidemment donc en se fondant un petit
peu justement sur cette question de de
North stream l'extrapolant parce que
sous les mers on va trouver des gazoducs
on va trouver des câbles de
télécommunication on va trouver des
câbles électriques de plus en plus
d'ailleurs c'est une question qui
souvent est un petit peu j'allais dire
un petit peu oublier mais il y a
énormément de câbles électriques qui
sillonnent notamment la mer Baltique et
demain potentiellement aussi la
Méditerranée et donc là j'en viens à ce
qui est aussi l'un des cœur de
développement aujourd'hui de la Marine
nationale qui est la question de la
maîtrise des fonds marins si aujourd'hui
la marine veut regarder sur les fonds
marins et veut avoir la capacité de
connaître et d'intervenir sur les fonds
marins c'est aussi et surtout en lien
avec la protection de ces
infrastructures critiques il y a un
certain nombre de pays dans le monde qui
développent ses capacités là la Chine
les États-Unis Israël la Russie donc
toutes les grandes puissances travail à
avoir des capacités qui sont liées
justement à la protection de ces
infrastructures critiques notamment en
mer puisqu'on parle de maritimisation
des flux énergétiques que ce soit
vis-à-vis d'acteurs terroristes ou
d'acteurs étatique donc c'est des choses
qui sont déjà on va dire prises en
compte et en développement voir pour un
certain nombre de capacités déjà tout à
fait existantes alors sur la question du
nucléaire
en 2022 donc avant ce conflit l'acteur
extrêmement dominant dans le nucléaire
dans le monde s'appelait la Russie
donc aujourd'hui on fait face justement
à ce duopole russe aux Chinois dans la
on va dire non pas la maîtrise mais le
développement d'une technologie dite de
quatrième génération notamment réacteur
à neutrons rapides dont l'intérêt
principal une fois que cette technologie
sera mature et de ne pas produire de
déchets de longue vie de fonctionner
dans ce qu'on appelle le cycle fermé de
l’uranium donc de produire des déchets
qui ne sont que réutilisables et donc
ils ne vont pas créer les problèmes
qu'on utilise c'est une technologie qui
était en cours de développement en
France jusqu'à l'arrêt du développement
du réacteur Astrid
donc aujourd'hui il faut reconnaître que
les pays traditionnels du nucléaire
historiquement que sont les États-Unis
les pays européens et le Japon sont en
recul par rapport à la Chine et à la
Russie néanmoins comme vous le
mentionniez il y a énormément de projets
qui foisonnent notamment de SMS alors
qu'ils soient de 4e génération pas de 4e
génération pour l'instant ils le sont
pas pour la plupart d'entre eux c'est de
la génération 3 plus donc c'est la même
chose que que les EPERS en termes de
paradigmes de production mais il est
bien clair qu'aujourd'hui les États-Unis
ont énormément investi là-dessus avec
une architecture étatique
multi-agence donc le département énergie
mais on va aussi trouver le deepartment
of defense of Commerce le deepartment of
state qui vont soutenir un certain
nombre de projets portés eux par des
acteurs privés notamment Bill Gates mais
qui n'est pas le seul acteur qui va
porter ses projets de développement de
petits réacteurs nucléaires alors la
question de la modularité est très en
question sur ces modèles là mais il est
bien évident que le jour où ces
réacteurs seront matures ils vont
déverrouiller de nouvelles applications
pour le nucléaire et plus uniquement un
nucléaire qui a vocation de production
électrique avec une utilisation de
l'électricité pour elle-même mais on
peut penser à du nucléaire de CO
génération électricité chaleur du
nucléaire d'électricité exclusivement
pour de l'hydrogène voire quand on va
penser à de l'exploration spatiale
profondeur du nucléaire de propulsion
quand on va commencer à s'intéresser de
plus en plus à la lune et à mars il est
bien évident que là on va voir aussi le
retour du nucléaire on voit par exemple
au Royaume-Uni Rolls-Royce a signé avec
le l'équivalent britannique du CNES un
accord de développement d'un réacteur
nucléaire destiné à l'exploration
spatiale profonde donc là effectivement
on a un vrai foisonnement de projet mais
qui dit foisonnement de projet dit aussi
foisonnement d'applications donc on sera
pas forcément sur un phénomène de le
premier entrant va prendre tout le
marché parce que les marchés devraient
conditionnel tendre à se diversifier là
aussi
tous les deux un mot sur la spéculation
sur la question sur la spéculation
que sur la Chine
alors sur la spéculation merci de me
poser cette question il va falloir 6
heures à peu près pour pour aller
là-dessus donc merci
6 minutes
c'est une question
ultra importante qui n'est pas
suffisamment évoquée c'est à dire qu'il
y a un côté un peu
on en parle tout le temps et finalement
on en parle jamais parce que la notion
de spéculation c'est la foi très
pratique c'est à dire qu'on va dire bah
finalement il y a une augmentation des
prix du gaz du blé ainsi de suite c'est
la spéculation comme ça pardonnez-moi de
le dire comme ça mais politiquement
c'est assez pratique c'est-à-dire que on
va cibler un spéculateur et on se pose
pas les vraies questions la spéculation
on doit faire la différence entre deux
choses je vais essayer d'être assez
schématique dans mes propos d'abord la
spéculation physique et la spéculation
financière
la spéculation physique elle est
finalement assez normale ça s'appelle du
stockage c'est à dire que si moi demain
je pense que les prix du gaz ou que
l'hiver 2023 va être compliqué il va
falloir que je fasse du stock
c'est-à-dire que je dis que les
conditions de prix d'aujourd'hui sont
plus intéressantes que les prix les
conditions de prix de demain et c'est
pour ça que j'achète aujourd'hui et que
j'attends pas demain vous voyez le truc
donc ça c'est il y a une dimension assez
naturelle on va appeler sa stockage mais
ça reste techniquement une forme de
spéculation puisque vous faites des
anticipations sur les niveaux de prix
après évidemment il y a cette
spéculation financière qui pose beaucoup
de problèmes la spéculation financière
c'est que vous allez utiliser ce qu'on
appelle des produits dérivés des
contrats à terme pour pour spéculer et
c'est là où ça devient compliqué parce
que j'ai entendu certains responsables
politiques dire mais regardez
90% à 95% des matières premières sont
cotées en bourse c'est vrai
disent et regardez ces contrats
financiers ne donnent pas lieu à de la
livraison physique de matières premières
alors que techniquement c'est possible
c'est vrai
et de conclure regardez c'est le monde
est fous puisque finalement la
spéculation est partout
le point clé à comprendre c'est que
c'est contrats à terme leur premier rôle
c'est de gérer l'instabilité des prix
d'accord vous gérez l'instabilité des
prix parce que cette instabilité des
prix vous l'aurez en permanence sur
l'ensemble des matières premières donc
là on parle de financiarisation c'est
d'ailleurs l'idée que vous allez gérer
l'instabilité des prix des matières
premières et le
l'agriculteur va être exposé à la baisse
des prix l'agroalimentaire va être
exposé là hausse des prix donc on a
besoin de ces outils pour gérer
l'instabilité donc ça c'est la
financièreisation mais la condition de
la financiarisation c'est la spéculation
c'est là que c'est de marcher ne
fonctionne pas si vous n'avez pas des
spéculateurs tels qu'on peut l'entendre
c'est-à-dire des fonds d'investissement
c'est à dire des ce qu'on appelle des
fonds spéculatives ou des traders ainsi
de suite une fois qu'on a dit ça
qu'est-ce qu'on dit
faut-il supprimer la spéculation
financière si la réponse est oui
et ça c'est une réponse politique qui
convient de donner si la réponse est oui
ça veut dire que l'on doit supprimer les
marchés à terme de matières premières et
si on supprime les marchés à terme de
matières premières on supprime des
solutions de gestion du risque de prix
voulant dire que vos industriels ou le
monde agricole reste face aux problèmes
de départ comment est-ce qu'il gère
cette instabilité posant une fine et la
question du rôle de l'État
fondamental pour gérer cette instabilité
des prix donc vous voyez qu'il y a une
sorte d'ambiguïté sur le propos vous
voulez arrêter la spéculation très bien
la spéculation financière puis
c'est-à-dire tous les États doivent
absorber toutes les variations des prix
et c'est quand même pas le sens que l'on
prend aujourd'hui notamment sur on
regarde par exemple la pâte
donc sur la Chine et vis-à-vis de votre
question sur ce que pourrait être la
reprise de la demande chinoise chinoise
pardon malheureusement je ne pourrais
faire qu'une réponse de Normand mais qui
est celle qui est la plus en tout cas
sur la base des données qu'on a la plus
fiable possible ce qui est sûr c'est que
l'année dernière on a eu encore une fois
une situation inédite avec le premier
importateur de gaz mondial qui pour la
première fois en 40 ans a vu sa demande
déclinée
c'était
jusqu'à présent était plutôt sur on a
toujours eu une tendance haussière en
Chine au rythme de son développement qui
comme vous le savez a été exceptionnel
au cours des 30 dernières années
l'année dernière juste sur vraiment le
segment gaz naturel liquéfié il y a eu
une diminution de 10% de la demande
chinoise et qui a permis
de alors relaxer le marché c'est
peut-être un petit peu un petit peu trop
abusif en termes de choix de mots mais
qui a permis notamment à l'Union
européenne plus de la clémence de
l'hiver de passer la crise sans rupture
d'approvisionnement ça a été l'un des
principaux facteurs comme on l'a rappelé
en première partie
et encore une fois en tout cas au niveau
de l'Agence internationale énergie et je
pense pas qu'il y ait d'autres
observateurs qui soient plus ferme en
tout cas dans leur projections
la conclusion quand on regarde la la
réouverture l'abandon des mesures
covid-19 chinoise mais également les
traces que cette
politique de de gestion de la pandémie
ont laissé et sont susceptibles de
laisser l'année prochaine on est encore
une fois vraiment dans l'incertitude sur
la dynamique de reprise de la demande
chinoise alors bien évidemment on a fait
des projections la plus
la plus brutale de ces projections nous
dit que en 2023 on pourra avoir une
reprise d'un peu plus d'un tiers de 35%
de la demande de gaz naturel liquéfié en
Chine
mais encore une fois on est sur un
spectre de scénario extrêmement large et
ce sera l'une des grandes incertitudes
qui vont notamment dicter les
comportements des acteurs sur le marché
en tout cas dans le trimestre qui vient
voilà malheureusement je peux pas être
plus
le président est de retour
une petite question complémentaire sur
le nucléaire j'étais en train de
regarder mes notes antérieures lorsque
Jean-Yves le compte a aborder le sujet
la France ça fait le choix de relancer
massivement le nucléaire certains nombre
d'autres pays s'y intéressent aussi or
quand on regarde l'origine de l'uranium
on constate que pour ce qui concerne la
France 34% de la Pro de des livraisons
venait du Niger 29% du Kazakhstan où il
y a 40% des réserves mondiales
26%, 12 baies distants et 10%
d'Australie
les trois premiers pays sont pas des
pays
particulièrement stable donc ma question
est simple c'est quels sont les risques
géopolitiques liés à l'approvisionnement
de l'uranium pour les amener à venir
alors déjà effectivement ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que l'uranium naît que le
composé d'entrée de la chaîne de valeur
du nucléaire voire du combustible
nucléaire je rentre même pas sur le
nucléaire juste sur le combustible
nucléaire c'est la donnée d'entrée mais
c'est une donnée d'entrée qui est quand
on va regarder sur l'ensemble de la
chaîne de valeur relativement marginal
on n'est pas du tout sur le même effet
qu'on peut avoir sur le pétrole ou le
gaz l'uranium c'est certain il en faut
hein on peut pas faire de combustible
nucléaire sans uranium pour le moment
avec des avancées sur le combustible on
pourra éventuellement fabriquer à partir
d'autres matières fissibles comme le
thorium mais pour l'instant c'est pas
forcément c'est pas forcément envisagé
de manière relativement forte mais c'est
une part on va dire qui est marginale
sur l'ensemble de la chaîne de valeur
une fois de plus quand on le compare aux
hydrocarbures il faut voir qu'on a
aujourd'hui
des stocks de combustibles et pas
d'uranium qui permettent de durer
pendant de nombreuses années en France
mais aussi il y a un acteur que vous
avez pas cité qui a un acteur
extrêmement important dans la fourniture
d'uranium c'est le Canada
les deux plus gros producteurs
aujourd'hui si on excepte le Kazakhstan
c'est le Canada et l'Australie la France
est de moins en moins exposée notamment
au Niger notre exposition au Niger ne
cesse de diminuer justement pour se
réorienter vers ces pays-là sachant
qu'il y a d'autres pays qui sont des
pays producteurs d'uranium potentiels ou
réel avec des niveaux bien moindre mais
comme les États-Unis la Namibie
éventuellement l'Afrique du Sud donc il
y a des sources alternatives voilà mais
il y a surtout ce double pilier on va
dire Canado australien qui permet
justement le Canada est en plus membre
de l'Otan d'avoir là pour le coup une
sécurité qui est quand même beaucoup
plus on va dire assurer tenant en compte
le fait que l’uranium est une part
certains portante mais mineur de la
chaîne de valeur du combustible
l'important étant la capacité
d'enrichissement et de fabrication du
combustible qui elle est
franco-française
oui juste peut-être évoqué
deux éléments d'abord revenir parce que
je ça me semble important sur la
question du gaz avec vous êtes au
courant de ça deux projets concurrents
qui approvisionneraient l'Europe
au départ du Nigéria un projet qui
passerait donc le transsaharien qui
amènerait donc le gaz en Algérie pour
fournir l'Europe et un projet concurrent
par l'Afrique de l'Ouest qui
alimenterait l'Europe par par le Maroc
évidemment ça va impliquer des choix
très compliqués de ce point de vue là
donc je pense que ça fait aussi partie
de l'équation sur le nucléaire
évidemment tout à fait d'accord c'est à
dire que finalement quand on parle de
matière première il faut la qualifier en
fait au sein d'une chaîne de valeur et
c'est là où on va avoir les points de
dépendance et les points de dépendance
ne sont pas toujours j'évoquais des
ressources minérales en amont mais
souvent dans la dans la transformation
sur les sms je crois qu'il y a une
question qui est aussi commune à
l'ensemble des énergies c'est la
question de l'accès l'acceptabilité
sociétale
vous avez vu par exemple le projet de
mine de lithium qui a tout de suite
finalement
engendrer des mécanismes d'opposition
par exemple en Bretagne on a des
solutions qui sont disponibles et
comment est-ce que les citoyens
intègrent ça dans leur pensée
c'est-à-dire dans le monde de demain qui
doit être en manque des carbonées il me
semble qu'il y a pas assez d'études pour
comprendre en fait les mécanismes
d'opposition à ces projets et ça semble
être un champ d'action politique
extraordinairement important
sensibilisation autour de la sobriété
énergétique et de la sobriété matière et
finalement
tout un travail de compréhension autour
de notre rapport à la matière le
président Macron évoquait la fin de
l'abondance on comprend évidemment le
concept je crois que nous rentrons dans
va nous rentrons à nouveau dans le monde
des matières premières nous découvrons
c'est pas la fin de l'abondance et le
début des matières premières
merci y a-t-il d'autres questions
je n'en vois pas bah écoutez je vous
remercie beaucoup d'abord de votre
disponibilité de vos réponses précises
c'est assez rare qu'on est des réponses
aussi spontanées aussi précis ça veut
dire que le sujet est parfaitement
maîtrisé et puis merci pour nous parce
que comme l'a dit Pierre auxilias au fil
des réunions on
clarifie une situation qui n'était au
départ pour nous que très flou donc
merci de nous permettre d'avancer dans
notre dans notre connaissance ça va nous
servir dans les les mois futurs dans
notre commission bien sûr mais aussi
pour les projets de loi qu'on va passer
ici notamment sur l'accélération des
aragies renouvelables sur sur
l'accélération nucléaire enfin il y a
beaucoup de choses qui qui vont nous
éclairer merci beaucoup